le coût de l'année 2023 vient peut-être
tout juste d'être joué au tournoi de
Formentera en Espagne ou le grand maître
indien aravine a joué dans cette
position l'extraordinaire d' MP3 mettant
sa dame en prise par le pion blanc alors
on se rend très vite compte qu'elle est
imprenable parce qu'après cavalier prend
B3 on aboutit un super match aller tout
fait le roi est coincé par ses propres
pièces mais ce coup est très loin de
juste faire joli outre la menace dame
prend deux avec un matelas suivre si les
blancs tentent de se créer une case de
fuite en E1 alors la foudre va s'avale
sur les sentiers dames et trois en
sacrifie de nouveau la dame le roi doit
la prendre après cavalier promo 4 c'est
un extraordinaire mat double échec à la
découverte dans la partie les Blancs ont
tenté de se défendre par tourcéen Tam
prend à trois ils ont un récupère la
pièce tours ces deux on défend le pion
après car il prend des trois le grand
maître a abandonné avec les Blancs
puisque sur dame prend tout prend ses
deux là deux possibilités pour prendre
avec la dame et cela faire Chloé ou
alors reprendre avec le roi et la perdre
de la même façon